Dameon I want to ask you about the first
conversations that you had with Ryan
about this project because it actually
predated la-la-land you had a chance to
read James Hanson's biography of Neil
Armstrong what did you see us your path
into it and what were the earliest
conversations that you had with Ryan and
then with Josh about the story inside a
very big book that you thought was the
most interesting one to tell well I
think the first thing it started with so
the the producers of the film with
Godfrey and Marty Bowen and Isaac
Klausner I had just finished whiplash
and been at Sundance with it and and was
back in LA and and they kind of
essentially they just asked me if I was
interested in Neil Armstrong and I said
no and and they gave me and they gave me
Jim Hansen's book that the movies based
on and I don't know I think it must have
sat there for a while I remember they
gave me some some DVDs of archival
material as well and just kind of left
me with it and for whatever reason at
some point weeks later I opened up the
book read a little bit popped in one of
the DVDs watched a little bit of the
material the archival material and and
something just sort of that I guess I
hadn't thought about the space race
before just sort of grabbed me it
suddenly seemed especially in Jim's book
more more dangerous more radical more
unlikely more even at times reckless
more at times heroic than than I had
then I guess I had given it credit for
in the past I think I subscribed to the
sort of rosy idea of NASA growing up as
certainly NASA in the 60s as being the
sort of unending string of successes you
know maybe a couple of issues here and
there but just in general just kind of a
sort of super heroic kind of group of
people doing super heroic things almost
as though they were easy and what Jim's
book really sort of and what Jim's
research into Neil specifically really
details that for Neil and for everyone
around him this was incredibly hard
which should be obvious but in a way it
was kind of successfully hidden from the
[ __ ]
so I just became fascinated by that by
this sort of the unmasked and stripping
away the mythology and and kind of
looking at the sort of Messier reality
underneath and that's what I kind of
first described to Josh and Josh started
working on the script and I'm gonna
describe to Ryan yeah before we before
we shot Lalo and you know this was the
first thing we kind of met about to talk
about Josh when you're thinking about
your approach this material in some ways
reminds me about your work on spotlight
that you're really interested in the
nuts and bolts shoe leather aspect of
the work that in spotlight is about how
journalists went about putting together
story and in first man it's really about
the day-to-day work that goes into
something like this was that something
that you found narrative ly interesting
that the more you talked about the the
work as opposed to the heroism of the
work it became a more personal story for
you yeah I mean like Damian I was you
know when Damian first pitched this to
me I was very interested in Damian
because I had watched whiplash and was
blown away like I think a lot of folks
were but I didn't know much about Neil
and as Damian said I was just knocked I
mean you guys have just seen he lost two
of his closest colleagues within 12
months and after the first of them died
Elliot see he had to go up in gym and I
ate and he almost died just the the the
the sequence of tragedies and losses and
failures and and the way they piled up
you know there's a great statement
engineering is the obvi a ssin of
failure right which to me is in some
ways sums up the movie and so I just got
really sort of taken by those details I
will say you know it was such a
provocative portrait of the space race
and of Neil in particular so different
from all the portraits that have come
before that we really felt a need to be
accurate in some detail which was
totally mind-numbing it times especially
with the technical stuff but you know we
felt like we had to get it right in
order to help you know makes sure our
thesis was clear Justin you have a long
relationship with Damian when you're
thinking about music
for this film there's a little dance
number you play this little waltz during
the Gemini docking which seems like a
little salute to lala land but
somatically what were the kinds of
things you were working toward and how
did you end up orchestrating a theremin
into a lot of the score yeah so we we
start with melody we just at the very
beginning I just work at a piano and
send I'd piano demo after piano demo
today me and until we kind of Block in
on the right theme or themes so we just
there were certain words we just talked
about the beginning like grief pain
loneliness a sort of cosmic pain a sort
of pain that could sort of transcend you
know the earth bound story and carry us
all the way to some of those space
scenes it could be used very in a very
grounded way at the beginning of the
story but then it could sort of be
orchestrated later on to be big and
grand something that could work on the
harp at the very beginning with the
family and with Karen but then also work
in those action scenes work in the
landing in a sort of grand way but still
in even when it's been used in its
biggest most action-packed form it still
is infused with that same pain that's
been you know motivating or underlined
the whole Neil's whole journey to that
point so I was looking for that melody
what could that melody be and we found
that after a couple months and then
started talking about sounds and how to
how to orchestrate it and something
Damian talked about from the beginning
is we wanted it to sound kind of have
some otherworldly tones to it to have an
orchestra but to to mix some things into
the orchestra that would make it just a
little different so that's where the
theremin idea came from Darren Damian
mentioned the theremin so I got one and
started messing around and learning how
to play it and I'm I I I think my
technique would probably appalled a real
theremin player I sort you're supposed
to have you know these very sort of fine
hand positions I just wave my whole hand
at it
but I learned to do the the melody for
this and sort figure out how to mix it
in how to lay it into the orchestra and
have it sit so it could sort of give a
little bit of that otherworldly quality
without it being overly we didn't want
it to be overly cute or sci-fi so
finding that the arrangements where it
could sit in the orchestra that was um
that was another another one of her
challenges I think I'm gonna ask you
about the opening scene and your use of
sound in it because there are so many
elements there's needles breathing or
Brian's breathing
there's rattles there's communication
there's instruments there's engines and
there's silence when you're thinking
about what you're trying to create
because there's very little there's no
dialogue in that opening sequence
how are you building sound to tell story
and why was silence so important there
and at other places in the film well
much earlier on you know basically you
know in these cockpit sequences you know
I had an early conversation with Damian
you know he wanted the sound to be
really like immersive and tactile at the
same time in space travel to have this
like chilling quality so for the opening
in the x-15 we introduced like rocket
sounds that we had recorded during
production and pre-production time and
oh so you know with the image and we are
always inside the cockpit with Neil from
his perspective so to create that really
you know intense visceral turbulence so
we also recorded some motion simulator
rights when the Machine injects low
frequencies to like heavily shake and
vibrate the entire vehicle just so it
has this tight space and you know we
have to constantly build an intensity
and you know to make it feel dangerous
so no besides playing some of the
authentic sounds wherever we can
including
a sonic boom when x-15 goes past the
atmosphere which we recorded from a
spacex falcon he be recording its we
also want Damien want it to like for us
to go into like this more of an
emotional journey for Neil on how he
felt and so you know we had to go into
something more like surreal or
surprising we kind of thought maybe
let's try introducing some animal vocals
on his way up into the Earth's
atmosphere so we start introducing like
an elephant roars lion growls animal
stampede
they'll just build up to the point where
like you know Neil can couldn't like he
reached the point and he flipped the
switch and you know these scenes are
important for the sound to give it like
there's a sense of like unease and
surprise so in the mix we played with
dynamics clear there's not a lot Neil
was not somebody who talked a lot about
his personal life a lot of people he
work with didn't know that he had a
daughter and very few people knew that
he had a daughter who died when you're
thinking about what you know about his
marriage and what you know about Janet
how much can you get from relatives from
family members and where did you find
your way in in terms of getting an
understanding of what she was like and
what her marriage was like well that's
the thing they were very private people
not just in a kind of public sense but
with their friends and family as well I
think our main resources I think
especially for me anyway were Rick and
Mark whether their children and children
don't really know a lot about their
parents married life really
it seems you sort of don't want to know
all that stuff so a lot of it is kind of
piecing things together understanding
what these two people are like as
individuals and then you know doing the
work which you know we're required to do
which is trying to understand what they
feel in those situations and things but
Jan I found there were so many people
who wanted to share memories of her and
talk about her
which is a very very impressive woman
and that can be slightly daunting when
everybody you talked to has its sort of
incredible memories of this really
capable amazing woman but yeah the more
I learned about her the more I was
amazed by how she held it all together
for as long as she did really Ryan James
Hansen who wrote the biography of Neil
Armstrong said that when asked how the
landing changed Neil Armstrong he said I
couldn't think of a person who has
changed less by it and I think that says
a lot about Neil Armstrong that for him
the mission was more important than what
it meant to him and when you were
thinking about playing a private person
and somebody who was uncomfortable in
many ways with the acclaim and that he
received what was your path in and what
were your earliest conversation with
Josh and Damian about what you felt were
important about capturing the essence of
a person who is very hard to pinpoint
well I've never had more help on film in
my life which is a testament to Neil and
Janet everybody who knew them wanted to
help us they wanted to give us any any
antidote or you know small piece of
information or interaction that they had
had even when I went to NASA people who
had only had Neil passed by them would
want to tell me you know how just how he
looked at them or the way that he
regarded them it was it just felt I felt
this overwhelming amount of support and
certainly from their their sons which I
think was the most difficult part of the
film was knowing that they were going to
see this film and they weren't going to
see a film about historical figures
they're gonna see a film about their mom
and dad and Neil sister June she she met
us at the you know in the room Neil was
born at the farm that he was raised and
she
an embodied Neil for me in the living
room and she she did her impersonation
of him for me
uh-huh you know with the love that a
sister has for her brother it was it was
really so beautiful
so yes Nia was very private a lot of
people felt as though he was very remote
he was many different things at
different points in his life you know if
you will look at him at in the USO tours
with Bob Hope after the missions he's
very funny and a very different person
but but that was in there it's just
we're seeing him at a very specific time
in his life and we start with this this
loss that is I think for me unimaginable
I think I'm not sure how anyone ever
ever deals with that and and and I
really just my heart broke for Neil and
Janet and to be then thrust into the
spotlight and handed this responsibility
of putting a human being on the moon
whilst trying to deal with that and to
deal with it with the Grace and the
elegance and the the fierce sense of
privacy and that they handled it it's
just I really fell in love with them I
really admired them it's very hard to
find out things about them and and that
made me respect respect him even more so
there was not one Pacific Avenue to
accessing him it really was every little
bit of information from all the people
along the way that wanted to help that
helped to add some color and and and
texture to to a couple that I thought
was really deserving of this tribute
that the film was trying to pay to them
thank you for bringing your film with us